Napoléon, Gengis Khan,
Alexandre le Grand, Jules César.
Ces grandes figures historiques sont réputées
pour être des conquérants.
Mais parmi eux, lequel peut être considéré comme
LE plus grand conquérant ?
Thibault, de la chaîne Histoire Appliquée,
est ici dans l'atelier pour nous répondre.
Allez, chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux,
on vous embarque
pour un bond dans le temps
et dans l'Histoire.
Et oui, Jamy,
c'est une très bonne question.
Qui est le plus grand conquérant de l'Histoire ?
Pour y répondre, il faut commencer
par se poser une autre question.
Sur quels critères doit-on se baser ?
Alors si la grandeur était proportionnelle
à la taille,
pas sûr que Napoléon l'emporterait.
Il ne mesurait qu'un mètre soixante-huit.
Cela dit, il y a fort à parier
que Jules César et Gengis Khan
n'étaient pas beaucoup plus grands.
Plus sérieusement,
la réponse à cette question dépend principalement du référentiel.
Si on raisonne
en termes de territoires conquis,
le grand gagnant est Gengis Khan,
le Mongol.
Avec l'aide de ses redoutables cavaliers,
il a réussi à constituer un empire qui va
de la Méditerranée à la mer du Japon,
soit plus de 30 millions de km².
Si l'on se réfère à l'impact sur nos institutions contemporaines,
Napoléon remporte la partie haut la main.
La France a conservé certaines institutions
mises en place par l'empereur.
C'est le cas
d'une bonne partie du Code civil,
l'organisation en départements,
la Banque de France,
et sans parler du paysage :
l'Arc de triomphe,
les platanes sur les bords des routes
et plusieurs dizaines de monuments dans tout le pays.
Si l'on se cale sur l'héritage culturel européen, Jules César
et les Romains en général,
pourraient réclamer
la première marche du podium.
Plusieurs langues européennes sont issues du latin,
comme le français, l'italien ou l'espagnol.
De même, la culture des Romains a considérablement influencé
les arts à la Renaissance, mais aussi l'architecture et la politique.
Les rois et empereurs
s'en sont souvent inspirés
pour eux-mêmes
avoir l'air de héros antiques
et marquer l'Histoire.
Tu vois, Jamy, c'est une question de point de vue
et je n'oublie pas que
dans ta liste,
il y en a un dont on n'a pas parlé,
c'est Alexandre le Grand.
Et c'est justement lui qui, selon moi,
mérite le titre de plus grand conquérant.
Son impact politique et culturel
a été si fort en son temps
qu'il a laissé des traces
plus de 2300 ans après.
Et pour comprendre mon choix,
il faut se pencher
sur son incroyable épopée.
Alexandre le Grand est né en 356,
avant l'ère chrétienne en Macédoine.
Alors, la Macédoine à l'époque,
ça n'est pas une salade de légumes,
mais un petit pays situé
entre la Grèce actuelle
et un État plus récent que l'on nomme
la Macédoine du Nord.
Il y a 2400 ans,
les Macédoniens sont considérés
comme des demi-Grecs
ou des demi-barbares.
Pas vraiment des Grecs, donc, mais proches d'eux tout de même.
Le pays est d'ailleurs fortement
influencé par la culture grecque.
À cette époque, la Grèce n'est pas un pays,
mais un territoire composé
de plusieurs grandes cités
puissantes et indépendantes.
La Macédoine, elle, est bien un pays,
c'est une monarchie élective
où le roi est donc élu.
Enfin, ça, c'est la théorie.
Dans les faits, les fils succèdent aux pères
qui eux-mêmes succèdent à leur père
qui eux-mêmes
succèdent à leur père, etc.
Ce non-respect
de la règle élective entraîne
de nombreuses querelles internes,
parfois très violentes,
qui font de la Macédoine
un pays profondément instable.
Toutefois, ce désordre fait des heureux.
La cité d'Athènes
et la proche région grecque de Thessalie
profitent de ce désordre
pour tirer parti des richesses
et des ports macédoniens.
L'avenir du pays est donc plutôt incertain.
C'est dans ce contexte troublé
que Philippe,
le père d'Alexandre le Grand,
arrive au pouvoir et il ne tarde pas
à rétablir l'ordre.
En quelques années, il parvient à imposer de grandes réformes
qui assurent la paix
avec les voisins belliqueux.
Il en profite aussi
pour solidifier et stabiliser
le système politique macédonien.
Il crée par exemple une armée de métiers articulée autour
d'une infanterie lourde équipée de grandes piques
qu'on appelle des sarisses.
On y trouve également
une cavalerie puissante
et des troupes plus légères pour appuyer cette infanterie lourde.
Philippe est aussi un habile politicien,
ce grand roi va de succès en succès,
tant militaires qu'économiques.
Sous son règne,
la Macédoine devient
l'une des premières puissances financières du monde.
C'est désormais un pays
avec lequel les cités grecques,
mais également la Grande Perse,
vont devoir composer.
Mais à l'été 336 avant l'ère chrétienne,
coup de théâtre,
Philippe est assassiné.
Le meurtrier n'est autre qu'un de ses gardes du corps.
Il se murmure que le commanditaire serait en réalité Olympias,
son épouse, la mère d'Alexandre.
Pour une histoire de jalousie, peut-être ?
La question reste sans réponse.
Ce qui est sûr, en revanche,
c'est que ce meurtre propulse soudainement
le jeune Alexandre sur le trône.
Il n'a pas encore 20 ans et possède déjà
une solide expérience de la guerre.
Il a participé à certains des exploits militaires de son père
et s'est révélé un excellent meneur d'hommes.
Alexandre veut à présent poursuivre seul l'œuvre de Philippe
et aller chercher sa propre gloire.
Ce ne sera pas dans un énième conflit avec les Grecs.
Les relations de la Macédoine
avec ses voisins semblent enfin apaisées.
Pour Alexandre, l'ennemi à abattre, c'est la Perse.
Il rêve d'unir l'Orient et l'Occident
et répandre la culture hellénistique partout dans le monde.
La Perse, immense empire oriental,
qui s'étend de la Libye à l'Inde actuelle,
est sur le chemin de ses rêves.
En plus d'être un réservoir inépuisable d'hommes et de richesses,
c'est aussi une puissance belliqueuse
qui a de nombreuses fois tenté de conquérir les cités grecques.
Envahir cette superpuissance de l'époque,
c'est donc le premier objectif d'Alexandre.
Il lance une première offensive en 334, avant l'ère chrétienne.
C'est la bataille de Granique
dans les Dardanelles
qui se solde par un succès éclatant.
Alexandre n'aurait perdu que 110 hommes sur une armée qui en comptait 35000.
C'est probablement un peu exagéré.
Sur sa lancée, le jeune conquérant décide de poursuivre sa route
sans trop s'éloigner des côtes.
Et il remporte une nouvelle bataille,
à Issos, en Syrie.
Cette fois l'armée perse est écrasée.
Elle ne parvient plus à offrir de résistance à Alexandre, qui poursuit
son périple sur d'autres territoires bordant la Méditerranée.
Il arrive ainsi à Tyr, un immense port phénicien.
Mais ici, les choses s'avèrent beaucoup plus compliquées.
En effet, Tyr est une ville fortifiée située sur une île.
La configuration difficile des lieux
empêche les armées d'Alexandre
d'être pleinement efficaces.
Quant aux Phéniciens,
ils se battent comme des lions
et refusent de se rendre.
C'est le point de départ
d'un siège qui sera long et difficile
pour les Macédoniens.
Il faut huit mois à Alexandre pour arriver à ses fins.
Mais une fois dans Tyr,
il ne se contente pas de prendre le contrôle de la ville.
Il en profite pour réduire sa population à l'esclavage pour l'exemple.
Fort de son succès, il libère l'Égypte de la domination perse
et se fait proclamer pharaon
dans la foulée.
Au même moment,
un autre événement finit de lui donner
une aura exceptionnelle.
Un oracle lui annonce
qu'il n'est pas le fils de Philippe,
mais bien le fils de Zeus en personne,
le dieu des dieux.
Et ça change tout !
Aux yeux de tous,
Alexandre est désormais perçu comme un demi-dieu.
Il est acclamé comme un libérateur, adulé par ses hommes
et admiré par la plupart de ses contemporains.
Pourtant, le jeune chef n'en est encore
qu'au début de ses conquêtes.
Il faut attendre 331 avant l'ère chrétienne
et la bataille de Gaugamèles
pour avoir une nouvelle démonstration de son génie militaire.
Alexandre fait subir
une terrible humiliation
à Darius III, roi des rois perses,
pourtant à la tête d'une armée
six fois supérieure en nombre à la sienne.
Babylone, Suse, Persépolis.
Toutes les grandes villes perses tombent les unes après les autres.
Darius est misérablement assassiné
lors de sa fuite
face à l'avancée d'Alexandre.
Ce dernier est désormais maître de l'empire qu'il convoitait
et il n'a pas l'intention de s'arrêter
en si bon chemin.
Il poursuit son aventure
toujours plus à l'est,
jusqu'à l'actuel Pakistan,
au pied de l'Himalaya.
Il y fait la connaissance de peuples
dont personne en Macédoine et en Grèce,
ne soupçonnait l'existence.
Toutefois, après près de dix années
de batailles, de voyages et de conquêtes,
le conquérant se voit contraint
de faire demi-tour.
Son armée est à bout de souffle.
Il s'installe définitivement à Babylone, la nouvelle capitale
de son gigantesque empire
qui s'étend du Pakistan à la Grèce.
En 323, avant l'ère chrétienne à Babylone,
Alexandre tire sa révérence.
Cet homme que rien ne semblait pouvoir
arrêter, est terrassé par la maladie.
Il n'a que 32 ans.
Après sa mort,
son empire sera partagé entre ses plus fidèles généraux.
Mais ces royaumes de culture grecque,
souvent instables et éphémères,
cèdent peu à peu la place
à la nouvelle puissance montante de l'Antiquité :
Rome.
On a souvent
tendance à définir Alexandre
comme un génie militaire
et un homme cruel.
Ses grandes batailles, les habitants de Tyr réduits en esclavage
et la ville de Persépolis entièrement brûlée,
en sont de bons exemples.
On ne peut donc pas nier que la violence
soit indissociable de son règne.
Mais ce serait une erreur que de le réduire à cela.
Dans les territoires conquis,
il n'a pas toujours été considéré comme un tyran sanguinaire,
bien au contraire.
Alexandre s'est attaché à pacifier
les zones qu'il occupait.
Son objectif était de créer un immense territoire de culture grecque
dans le respect des usages locaux.
Il a ainsi favoriser la création de cités et de colonies mixtes
entre Grecs et natifs.
Une grande idée
même s'il n'est pas exclu qu'il
y soit parvenu par la force.
Il n'a pas cherché non plus à gommer les langues autochtones
et à veiller au respect des traditions dans chaque pays.
Il semble également avoir
pris le parti de conserver
les administrations en place en se contentant de les améliorer.
La présence d'Alexandre
le Grand aurait donc aussi été bénéfique
aux peuples conquis.
Il a renforcé le système monétaire,
construit de nouveaux réseaux routiers
et fondé un certain nombre de villes,
la plus célèbre étant bien sûr Alexandrie.
Bon je dis Alexandrie, mais je parle de celle d'Égypte,
parce qu'Alexandre avait tendance
à appeler toutes les villes qu'il fondait, Alexandrie.
Et il en aurait fondé entre 20 et 70.
Il fut donc un conquérant,
mais aussi un homme à l'ambition civilisatrice
qui restera un modèle pour beaucoup.
Dans l'Antiquité, son œuvre militaire fascine les plus grands hommes.
Jules César se réclame
de l'héritage d'Alexandre,
comme nombre d'empereurs romains
par la suite.
Plus tard, au Moyen Âge,
le Macédonien est l'un des héros
les plus connus
de la littérature médiévale grâce au Roman d'Alexandre.
Il s'agit d'un recueil de légendes et de poèmes autour de sa vie,
qui sera traduit dans des dizaines de langues partout dans le monde.
En Europe,
tous les grands monarques chercheront
à s'inspirer d'Alexandre le Grand.
Le plus célèbre d'entre eux,
c'est Napoléon.
l'Empereur l'érige en modèle.
C'est une inspiration pour sa capacité à organiser son armée
et les territoires conquis.
Aujourd'hui encore,
les batailles d'Alexandre
sont analysées dans les écoles d'officiers.
Pour les historiens contemporains,
le personnage conserve malgré tout
une grande part d'ombre.
À commencer
par les circonstances de sa mort.
A-t-il succombé à une maladie,
à un empoisonnement ?
Le débat n'est pas tout à fait tranché,
même si l'hypothèse de la maladie reste
tout de même la plus probable.
Mais la plus grande question
non résolue
concerne le lieu de sa sépulture.
Personne n'en connaît l'emplacement.
Il fut pourtant bien connu jusqu'à la fin de l'Empire romain.
Les empereurs allaient régulièrement
s'y recueillir,
certains pour lui rendre hommage,
comme Auguste,
d'autres pour chiper des morceaux de sa tenue funéraire
en guise de reliques.
Et puis, un beau jour, on perd sa trace.
Son tombeau a-t-il été déplacé ?
A-t-il été détruit ?
Nous n'avons absolument pas la réponse.
Chaque année ou presque,
il y en a toujours un pour affirmer
qu'il a mis la main
sur le tombeau d'Alexandre.
Mais bien sûr, c'est du vent.
La question continue d'alimenter
tous les fantasmes.
Pour finir,
je ne résiste pas au plaisir
de vous raconter
une petite anecdote
concernant l'héritage d'Alexandre.
C'est l'histoire de la causia.
Il s'agissait d'une sorte de béret plat,
plus ou moins grand, que portaient
les combattants macédoniens
et les monarques.
Ce couvre chef placé sous le casque, en temps de guerre,
devait être très utile.
Il permettait de créer un rembourrage qui absorbait les chocs
et améliorait le confort des guerriers.
Et ce béret, il ne vous dit rien ?
Il ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau au pakol.
le fameux chapeau afghan
porté aujourd'hui par les combattants dans cette région du monde.
Selon la légende,
les Afghans et les Pakistanais auraient adopté la causia
après le passage des armées d'Alexandre.
Puis il aurait traversé les âges
jusqu'à nous.
Alors pourquoi Alexandre est, selon moi,
le plus grand des conquérants ?
Parce qu'il cumule tous les critères des autres conquérants.
Vaste territoire conquis
comme Gengis Khan,
réorganisation administrative et traces durables dans notre quotidien
comme Napoléon
et impact culturel et politique
comme les Romains.
Après Alexandre,
toute personne ambitieuse
s'inspirera de lui,
et c'est bien pour ça
qu'il a acquis ce surnom
d'Alexandre le Grand.
Voilà Jamy,
j'espère t'avoir convaincu
qu'Alexandre le Grand est bien
le plus grand des grands conquérants.
Merci Thibault.
Si, comme moi,
cette vidéo vous a passionnés,
n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous abonner.
Si toutefois vous aviez
des suggestions de sujets
liés à l'Histoire, n'hésitez pas, proposez-les en commentaire.
À très bientôt.
Chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux !